foreign
meal of the day this school in Plymouth
has hungry mouths to feed and it's
harder than ever more free School meals
are coming through and than we had
previously so I guess that's a cost of
living it's
um having a big impact on parents
inflation may be coming down but food
prices are unrelenting they jumped by
another 19 in the year to March it's
enough to put anyone off their food it's
now very difficult to continue to
provide the quality and meet all of the
school food standards that were required
to meet every single day we've removed
beef from our menus because it's too
expensive so we we've stopped buying
from Cornish Farms to do that and we've
used more chicken and we use more Gammon
but even so the cost of those products
through animal feed affected by the war
in Ukraine have increased his worries
have been heard 200 miles away in
Westminster where policymakers are
desperately trying to get a grip on the
problem this is a small headline fall
but it disguises a large rise in food
inflation and it shows that there is no
such thing as an automatic fall in the
headline rate of inflation that's why we
have a plan and if we're going to reduce
that pressure on families it's
absolutely essential that we stick to
that plan and we see it through so that
we halve inflation this year as the
Prime Minister has promised
me out the bank of England is tasked
with bringing inflation down and it will
now have to turn things up a notch just
a few days ago the Outlook was brighter
but it's now almost certain that the
bank of England will have to raise
interest rates again next month in order
to combat inflation
but this medicine comes with pain of its
own and no one knows that better than
the millions of homeowners who could see
their monthly mortgage payments go up
again
so an unpalatable tonic for an
unpalatable problem that just won't
quite go away
no one Sky News